it can make you sweat cry and even send
you to the hospital this is the Carolina
Reaper the world's hottest pepper what
would happen if you ate one of these hol
what if you ate 1,000 of them
what makes this pepper so hot
how many can your body handle and how do
you survive something like this this is
whatever and here's what would happen if
you ate 1,000 of the hottest peppers in
the world
some people can eat incredibly spicy
peppers with no problem in fact people
have competitions where they eat dozens
of Carolina Reapers scientists think
that this might be psychological and
that these people have a higher pain
tolerance than those who cry after
eating a jalapeno so sure some people
can handle a Carolina Reaper too but
what would happen if you ate 1,000 of
them as soon as you pop the first pepper
into your mouth you'll begin to sweat
this is the first sign of your pain
responses being activated your
metabolism will also be kick-started
since you're sweating this will allow
you to burn some calories as you're on
this hot pepper binge it might not hit
you right away but you'll eventually
start to feel an intense burning
sensation on your tongue and then all
around your mouth whatever part of your
body is touched by the Carolina Reapers
oils will be at risk of feeling burning
and numbing
and you might want to wear some goggles
as getting any of this hot pepper in
your eyes will cause severe pain and
could even lead to blindness as the
pepper travels down your throat more
pain receptors will be activated you'll
continue to sweat and at this point you
might start crying but why is any of
this happening to you in the first place
well peppers are rated on the Scoville
heat scale for example a jalapeno pepper
has an 8,000 Scoville heat rating but
the thing we're eating the Carolina
Reaper is rated at 1.6 million Scoville
heat units which isn't much less than US
military grade pepper spray so yeah
these things are pretty hot and the way
these heat units are determined is based
on how hot the peppers capsaicin is
capsaicin is what produces that spicy
burning sensation we get from eating hot
foods
so now that you know a bit more about
these things and you've eaten a couple
of them how are you feeling
probably not all that great when the
pepper reaches your stomach it will mix
with your stomach acids your stomach
will start to make more acid than usual
and more mucus to protect itself from
the capsaicin this will make you
nauseous at this point you might want to
start chugging some milk or eating ice
cream
dairy products contain casein which
helps to neutralize the spicy compounds
giving you some relief if you don't like
dairy products and decide to drink some
water instead Oh huge mistake it does
nothing water spreads the capsaicin
around your body making your pain even
worse as you continue to eat these
peppers you'll continue to sweat cry and
feel sick to your stomach and then
you'll be running to the bathroom eating
all this spicy food will certainly lead
to diarrhea that's because when you're
digesting spicy food you absorb more
water which will lead you to sitting on
the toilet for some time but we're not
done yet
you still have hundreds of peppers to
eat as you continue to eat them you'll
eventually start vomiting and your body
will begin to reject on this capsaicin
but if you do manage to get them all
down you could suffer from a capsaicin
overdose which could then kill you but
everyone reacts to this level of
capsaicin differently
there have been some cases where eating
a single Carolina Reaper has led to
narrowing of the brain arteries and
massive headaches so if you're looking
to eat some spicy food maybe you should
just stick to pouring hot sauce on your
chicken wings consuming this much
capsaicin would certainly end up with
you being sent to the hospital but what
if instead of all these spicy peppers we
decided to eat mold oh that sounds like
a story for another what if
[Music]